the most valuable thing I own is
probably this five years ago I had a
chance to meet the individual behind how
to basic as a gift I was given this
which they had recently used in a video
I asked if they would sign it but they
had never signed an autograph before
didn't even know what to sign we worked
together to come up with this htb with
two eggs drawn on either side and then
the date underneath this may not be the
only autograph how-to basic has ever
done but it very well may be the first
but here's what's really wild I was so
nervous and so honored to meet the
actual mysterious how-to basic that I
took it really seriously I didn't tell
anyone their name I didn't even tell my
own wife and so for five years I just
didn't even think about their name today
I have forgotten it I literally forgot
who how to basic is if you kidnapped me
and tortured me to give you that
information I couldn't all I have is
this memory